NEW TONIGHT, I QUOTE, YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY WILL BE KILLED VERY
SLOWLY.
WE PLAN FOR THE DEATH OF YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY EVERY DAY.
SOMEONE IN YOUR FAMILY IS GOING
TO HAVE A VERY UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT.
TRISHA RAFFENSPERGER IS THE
WIFE OF GEORGIA'S SECRETARY OF
STATE BRAD RAFFENSPERGER.
SHE'S BREAKING HER SILENCE TO
REUTERS.
DISTURBING AND HORRIFYING
THREATS THAT HER FAMILY HAVE
ENDURED BECAUSE OF HER HUSBAND
SPEAKING THE BASIC TRUTH,
STANDING UP TO DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS BIG LIE THAT THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN FROM HIM.
SAID FACTS ABOUT WOULD HAPPEN
IN GEORGIA.
OUT FRONT NOW, BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER, AND SECRETARY I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
FRANKLY I AM SORRY TO BE
SPEAKING TO YOU UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT IT TAKES A
LOT OF BRAVERY AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT
IT.
I MEAN WHY IS TRISHA DECIDING
TO TELL US ALL OF THIS NOW, TO
SHARE THESE THREATS PUBLICLY?
>> I THINK IT WAS HELPFUL FOR
HER TO DO THAT.
PROBABLY TO GET IT OFF HER
CHEST, BUT ALSO TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT JUST HER.
IT'S ELECTION WORKERS, PEOPLE
ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE MARRIED TO AN OFFICIAL.
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THEMSELVES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE NEED
TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT THAT
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE BEHAVIOR.
THE THREAT, WIVES, CHILDREN,
FAMILIES, PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR
THE GOVERNMENT.
EVEN GOVERNMENT WORKERS.
THEY WEREN'T SET UP FOR THIS.
THEY DID NOT SIGN UP FOR THAT.
THERE ARE EMPLOYEES.
I DON'T BELIEVE ELECTED
OFFICIALS SIGNED UP FOR THESE
DEATH THREATS EITHER.
IT'S TIME ELECTED OFFICIALS ON
BOTH SIDES HOLD EACH SIDE
ACCOUNTABLE.
IF YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT SIDE,
OUR SIDE, WE NEED TO HOLD OUR
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND WE NEED
TO CLEAN UP OUR BACKYARD, JUST
LIKE THE LEFT NEEDS TO CLEAN UP
THEIR BACKYARD.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE OTHER
PERSON'S BACKYARD?
LET'S CLEAN UP OUR OWN BACKYARD.
WE NEED TO HAVE HONEST
DISCUSSIONS AND PUT INTEGRITY
BACK NOT JUST IN THE ELECTIONS
BUT ALSO IN OUR ELECTED
LEADERS.
>> SO TRISH TALKS ABOUT HOW
YOUR FAMILY WENT INTO HIDING.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
AGAIN, I KNOW IT'S HARD TO
SHARE BUT I THINK IT'S SO
POWERFUL.
YOU HAD TO GO INTO HIDING IN
LATE NOVEMBER AND THEN SHOOTERS
BROKE INTO THE HOME OF YOUR
DAUGHTER IN LAW, AND THAT SAME
NIGHT MEMBERS OF THE FAR-RIGHT
PRO TRUMP MOVEMENT OATH KEEPERS
WERE FOUND OUTSIDE YOUR HOME.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY THERE.
WE'VE NEVER KNOWN ANY OF THIS
BEFORE.
THIS --
I'M RAISING THIS POINT BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT JUST THREATS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY SHOWING UP.
WINDOWS CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS?
IT MUST HAVE BEEN TERRIFYING.
>> AT THAT POINT WE REALIZED --
IT SEEMED --
THEY WERE BASICALLY CASING OUR
HOUSE, SEEING THE SECURITY
MEASURES WE HAD.
AND SO WE JUST DECIDED THAT WE
WOULD TAKE AN EARLY
THANKSGIVING VACATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
>> SO YOU TRAGICALLY LOST YOUR
OLDEST SON AT THE AGE OF 37 IN
2018.
NOTHING COULD EVER REPLACE
THAT.
I KNOW YOUR WIFE TOLD REUTERS
THAT THAT TERRIBLE LOSS WEIGHED
HEAVILY ON HER.
AMID THESE THREATS.
SHE TOLD REUTERS, AND I QUOTE,
TRISHA, I HESITATE TO SAY THIS
BECAUSE I'M AFRAID SOMEONE
MIGHT USE IT AGAINST ME.
BUT YOU KNOW I'VE LOST A CHILD.
I DON'T EVER WANT TO GO THROUGH
THAT AGAIN.
BECAUSE OF THESE THREATS I KNOW
YOU AND TRISHA --
YOU ARE TIED TO YOUR SON.
TO FEEL SUCH FEAR, SECRETARY,
IT BRINGS TEARS TO MY EYES.
IT'S TRULY SICKENING.
>> WE JUST NEVER WANTED TO HAVE
OUR GRANDCHILDREN OVER HERE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THE SITUATION
AROSE.
EVEN IF IT WAS NOT A VIOLENT.
THANK PEOPLE SCRAPING,
HOLLERING, SHOUTING AT ME.
MY GRANDCHILDREN HEARING THAT,
AND YOU JUST THINK ABOUT THE
EMOTIONAL SCARS THAT COULD
HAPPEN TO THEM, BUT ALSO WOULD
IF THEY ARE ACTUALLY IN
PHYSICAL DANGER, THAT'S WHY WE
TOOK A SEVERAL MONTH BREAK OF
HAVING CHILDREN HERE UNTIL
THINGS STARTED CALMING DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
I SHOULD WRITE OFF THE TOP OF
YOUR PIECE.
SOME OF THOSE CAME IN AS LATE
AS --
I UNDERSTAND --
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
OTHER STATES.
OTHER STATE ELECTION OFFICIALS
ARE STILL BEING THREATENED
ALSO.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE ARE
APRIL 24TH OF THIS YEAR.
6 WEEKS.
SOMEONE USED A FAKE EMAIL
ADDRESS.
THEY USED YOUR NAME.
THEY TRIED TO MAKE IT APPEAR
THE MESSAGES WERE COMING FROM
YOU AND THAT THESE WERE AWFUL
THINGS AS WELL.
ABOUT TRISHA.
I QUOTE, I MARRIED A SICKENING
HORROR, I WISH YOU WERE DEAD.
YOU UNDERSTAFFED BELIEVE, THE
MOTIVE, I BELIEVE, WAS TO FORCE
YOU TO RESIGN.
TO JUST BREAK YOU.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T RESIGNED.
YOU KEPT STANDING UP FOR THE
TRUTH OF THE ELECTION, AND THAT
WAS THE FAIR OUTCOME IN
GEORGIA.
YOU ARE RUNNING FOR REELECTION.
I'M SURE, THAT WAS A VERY
THOUGHTFUL, AND DEEP
CONVERSATION, TO GET TO THAT.
AFTER EVERYTHING YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH, WE MADE YOU DECIDE TO
DO THAT?
I WANT TO STAY IN THIS?
I WANT TO READ A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL?
I WANT TO KEEP RUNNING?
>> PEOPLE QUESTIONING MY
INTEGRITY, WE MADE SURE WE HAD
AN HONEST AND FAIR ELECTION.
AND PEOPLE PUSH US OFF OUR
PROGRAM, OUR PLAN, AND I WON'T
DO THAT.
I NEED TO STAND FOR INTEGRITY.
WHAT I THINK, REALLY, IS
EMBARRASSING AS A REPUBLICAN,
IS THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD DO SUCH SHAMEFUL THINGS,
AND SAY SUCH SHAMEFUL THINGS,
THAT ARE JUST SO VILE.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT WE WERE THE
PEOPLE, WHERE OUR PARTY WAS
BETTER THAN THIS.
BUT THEN YOU START TO SEE THIS,
WE, EVERYONE ON MY SIDE, NEEDS
TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT WE NEED TO SAY IS
RESPECTFUL.
WE NEED AGREEMENTS, POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS, BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER, AND TALK TO EACH
OTHER, LIKE FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
THIS COUNTRY IS BIGGER THAN ONE
PERSON.
FOR EVERY SINGLE OFFICE.
WE'VE HAD GREAT OFFICERS, WE'VE
HAD GREAT CONGRESSES, PEOPLE IN
VERY DIFFERENT TO POSITIONS,
AND ALWAYS JUST BIGGER THAN ONE
PERSON, AND ONE TYPE.
IT'S A BIG COUNTRY, AND WE NEED
TO GET BACK, AND RUN HARD FOR
OUR ELECTIONS.
WHEN WE LOSE, WE NEED TO LEAVE,
AND WE CAN LEAVE QUIETLY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SECRETARY RAFFENSPERGER, I
APPRECIATE YOUR